so what I'm doing in this talk is asking
a question and I'm not necessarily going
to answer it I'm gonna give kind of a
suggestion of vague somewhat of a vague
answer and suggestion in the first part
and then a more concrete proposal in the
second part and so the first thing to
know about the phobia within the retinas
is a very special part of the retina and
it lies back here at the back of the eye
aligned with the axis of the lens and
one of the things that makes the fovea
very interesting is the the sting
structure called the fibers of Henle
which is so if you just zoom in on this
portions of the phobias back here this
little pit if you look at a
cross-section with us like a little kid
and if we just sort of zoom in on that
region zoom in on that region just one
half of it to see what it looks like
this is what you'll see in cross-section
the fovea is this part here these are
the photoreceptors these kind of
vertical segments here these are the
outer segments of the photoreceptors
these are the cell bodies of the
photoreceptors so here you are right
smack in the middle of the fovea you
know coordinate zero comma zero in the
retina and and so what these fibers of
Henle do is they allow the information
to get relayed from these photoreceptors
to the bipolar cells in the retinal
ganglion cells
okay so there's all these different
layers of the retina and so there's at
least two layers here the inner nuclear
layer which contains the bipolar cells
the amacrine cells and horizontal cells
and the ganglion cell layer here which
are pushed aside so normally if you just
looked at any other part of the retina
these layers are both of these layers
are sitting and this is sort of a more
typical pattern here right as you go
towards the periphery these layers are
sitting right on top of the
photoreceptors and the light of course
has to kind of go through all that and
there's obscuring things and so whoever
built this device said well look I don't
want that stuff there let's kind of push
it aside and make it someone else's
problem okay because I really want to
have good access to the light here very
high-resolution I'm packing in the
photoreceptors with highest highest
density here so this is I think an
interesting example where pure structure
pure morphology
makes very strong suggestions about what
the goals of the system are okay so
that's you know that system going to a
lot of effort to to do that to just sort
of clear away all of and all the junk
and make a good image for this poor so
this may be roughly like a hundred
hundred footer centers across here just
this zone and so these fibers of Henle
just bait you know so these these Gretna
ganglion cells they're they're far away
displace if you record it from the one
of these retinal ganglion cells here it
has a receptive field over here okay
it's not sitting right on top of that so
and then if now if we go a step further
this is the fiber so one step further
than the the we find that the retinal
ganglion cells are connected in the
one-to-one fashion with bipolar cells
okay so for each cone for each conferred
receptor there's two bipolar cells
reading it out one of the on type and
one of the off type and in the fovea for
each of those bipolar cells there's a
single retinal ganglion cell reading us
output out okay so it's that ratio is
one to one and that's not the cases
you're going to perfect there's more
pooling that happens at the retinal
ganglion cells but in the fovea it's
it's it's one to one okay so basically
for each cone in the fovea there's two
wires at least two wires maybe three
coming out coming out of the optic nerve
and then if we look at how they're
sampling a visual space this is just
showing the depiction made by Charlie
Anderson of how the retinal ganglion
cells are tiling visual space they're
packed most densely here in the center
there so they're sampling the visual
field very finely so one retinal
ganglion cell per bipolar cell per cone
and in in the center here and and then
they're their spacing is increasing
linearly with eccentricity according to
this formula here and okay so so these
so now this is sort of another sort of
you know allocation that's being made by
the system is that you're you're
achieving very high acuity here in terms
of degrees of visual space there's many
many
ganglion cells devoted per degree of
visual space here in the center as
compared with the as compared with the
periphery and the way that this spacing
increases with eccentricities cording
this formula it matches very nicely
although with a different slope the
psychophysics just the the the just the
nominal size you need to make a
character in order to be just a wreck
vil so this is just measurement by
Stewart Anstis just showing the the
threshold litter height the the height
of the letter or the width when it's
just barely legible discriminable okay
and that increases linearly with
eccentricity with a slope of 0.04 that
other one was a slope of 0.01 which
means there's roughly about 4 retinal
ganglion cell samples across the
character when when it's when is just
barely legible and this just shows what
that looks like when the letters are ten
times the threshold height okay so those
are easily easily legible here's when
you fixate the idea is when you fixate
the center here each of these letters is
subtending the same number of retinal
ganglion cells okay so it's constant in
terms of how many retinal ganglion cells
are sampling that pattern and they're
equally legible because of the spacing
in the retinal ganglion cells okay so so
this is another this is sort of you know
just one aspect of and that'd mean
physiology that's been known about for a
long time but where things quite start
to kind of get interesting is so you
know even though you have the same
number of retinal ganglion cells
spanning each these letters so this
should be equally legible funny things
start to happen in the periphery that
don't happen in the fovea so when you
fixate here in this cross you just hold
your eyes on the cross and you can
pretty easily I think you would agree
read that letter out there in the
periphery you can see that it's at and
you can make out the strokes of it and
let's see what it is but as soon as you
surround it by other stuff just keep
your eyes fixate fixed in the center you
can see that it's it kind of falls apart
right and this is a phenomenon oh that
is crowding and there's lots of models
lots of studies in this phenomenon and
it's thought to be something that has to
happen in the cortex because you have
plenty of retinal ganglion cells to here
to resolve all those strokes so it's not
like when you bring those surrounding
letters in that is somehow interfering
with the retinal ganglion cells you have
enough samples there to resolve that
structure so it's something the cortex
is doing to kind of group things
together and and muck things up so again
that's what it looks like in isolation
and and then here's what you saw
okay and then when we take the same
pattern and put it in the in the center
if you just sort of fixate there
hopefully that's visible to most of you
you know you can you know you can see
the end just find the stuff in this
round doesn't encroach it yeah
population can you decode it from that I
don't know that that's somebody's in
like a J would be the person to do that
or something like that but that they try
to do that exactly just based on you
know the the arguments the numbers of
retinal ganglion cells this is what you
would need and then it agrees with the
psychophysics right so that the
psychophysics matches the the anatomy
very well so that all kind of agrees
with each other so so then this is the
phenomena of crowding which is occurs in
the periphery here's just like a
real-life diamonds lips oops this is a
real live demonstration of crowding
where if you made by david whitney and
dennis lee vise if you just keep your
eyes on for the look of that bull's eye
in the center it's like you know if
you're driving and there's a
construction zone down that you're
paying attention to this construction
zone these two figures here the little
boy in yellow as you fix a there you'll
probably you can easily see the little
boy on the right but the little boy in
the left is getting kind of gunked
together with those construction signs
right it's sort of something it's kind
of getting messed up so again you have
enough retinal ganglion cells to resolve
that little boy there but something the
cortex is doing in the cortical
circuitry it's it's messing it up and so
this isn't just a laboratory phenomenon
you see here's another somewhat of a
laboratory phenom this is when one of
the best illusion of the wards at the SS
a few years ago so if you keep your eyes
on the fixation cross in the middle
during this movie so just keep your eyes
on the cross you'll see something
interesting thing happens to these faces
in the periphery just keep your eyes in
the fixation
do you notice the kind of most people
that kind of look grotesque
and bizarre right so when you look over
it when you fixate the person they look
you know they're enlarged they kind of
look a little strange but they don't
look like monsters when you look at them
right but in the periphery something
very strange is happening right so yeah
this was you know funky thing so who
knows why this is happening why they who
knows why they look like monsters but I
think again this is sort of similar
thing happening where in in the
periphery it's sort of subject to
getting messed up you know there's
something the cortex wants to do with it
and coerce the structure in certain ways
that doesn't happen in the fovea so you
know this is not something we
experienced in real life you know when
you scare someone's face and they
followed by someone else they don't look
strange right but this would happen with
color right if you followed one color by
another then the interpretation of a
color depends on what was seen
previously and so this though it's
thought to be sort of a short-term
adaptation effect as of might be sort of
one explanation behind what's happening
here okay so so here's some other ways
that the phobia starts to differ in in
how the visual information is
interpreted as we go deeper into the
system so this is showing a map of the
LGN spatial map of the LGN as compared
to the visual field so here's the whole
visual field out here different degrees
of eccentricity just one half of the
visual field as it's mapped on to one
LGN and here the surface of the cortex
okay so in the LGN about twenty percent
twenty percent of the surface area of
the map at the LGN falls within the
central five degrees of visual space
that's the stippled area here is the
central five degrees of visual space
which is barely visible there is just
this tiny part of the center here right
guess hugely mapped out here in the LGN
and the cortex it's about forty percent
right so this this this this five
percent the central visual field is
getting consumes about 40 percent of the
surface area of v1
okay so there's something interesting
happening here it's that first of all
you have this this magnification that's
happening because the retinal ganglion
cells are packed so densely in the
phobia as compared to periphery but
there's two other sources of
magnification that are happening here
one is within the LGN so there's just
there's about the same number of cells
in the LGN as retinal ganglion cells so
the number is roughly one to one but the
slope to that such that there's many
retinal ganglion cells I'm sorry
many LG n cells representing a single
retinal ganglion cell here and as you go
to the periphery there's fewer than one
okay so it's it's many to one in this in
the fovea and and you know one to one to
many as you go out to the periphery out
here okay so that's another added source
of magnification happening is that the
the LGN is over representing the fovea
as compared to the periphery in terms of
number of retinal ganglion cells not
degrees of visual space which would
already be inherent because of the
retinal ganglion cell sampling why they
say it's over sampling the number of
retinal ganglion cells okay in the fovea
and then again the same thing is
happening in the cortex and that's why
you know here it's only twenty percent
the central five degrees in the LGN and
it goes up to forty percent in the in v1
so even more you know even more sort of
hardware is being dedicated to to the
fovea okay and this just shows that
quantitatively the different slopes so
it's so within the end in the fovea
there's about ten times there's about
ten times as many cortical neurons
representing a single LGN neuron in the
fovea as compared to the periphery okay
so if you had equal densities or an
equal fan out from or equal ratio across
here from LGN neurons to cortical
neurons this line would be flat across
here okay they'll be totally flat but
it's not there's a slant so it's an
extra sort of amount of hardware by a
ratio of ten to one being dedicated to
the fovea and what's interesting here is
that's even more so for the Magno stream
okay so there there's even so within the
Magno stream there's the the number of
neurons and layer four see alpha is is
about 150 times larger in the pho that
many about a hundred fifty fold increase
in the phobia as compared the periphery
okay so why is this happening as far as
i know you know and nobody has any
explanation from this about this for
from a computational point of view like
what's what are the computations you're
doing with this extra amount of hardware
for the Magno stream of all things let
alone for the part of a string in the
center of vision okay so to me i just
want to want to put this out there
because i think it's a really
interesting kind of anatomical fact
about the system that i think a lot of
people have talked to you aren't largely
aware of the way that this that the
fovea is so highly
the system that suggests there's there's
something maybe qualitatively different
about the way information has been coded
and computed in the foveal region which
is a huge part of our visual experience
as compared to the periphery namely that
the periphery seems to be more sort of
subject to contextual influences but
top-down with influences and things can
kind of sort of slip around and move
around more whereas in the phobia at
least it seems like maybe you want to
sort of preserve information and keep
preserved spatial detail and sort of
keep that immune from from contextual
influences but again sort of how you
sort of put all this in computational
terms in quantitative quantitative Lee
has yet to be done so I'm going to throw
that out of the computational computer
yet computational community I think this
is a really interesting challenge to to
explain okay so one one one way we know
that the one problem that we know that
the fovea needs to deal with with which
the periphery does not need to deal with
is retinal drift so this is just a movie
of that from Austin weirdest lab where
these dots are showing individual cones
very close to the fovea and the subject
is just fixating and this e is being
flashed up there and it's a subject in
this experiment you can read that EU can
tell what orientations it's facing and
so forth and and to the subject looking
at this it looks stable okay so your
experience as a subject doing this
experiment you don't see the e moving
and you can read it okay which is really
interesting right because if you if you
sort of you know had a CCD engineer or
somebody designing cameras and obvious
maybe can testify this is true as well
that you know the first thing I would
say is like you know let's get rid of
motion I try to keep it still right it's
not going to help us particularly
interpret the image so so this so this
is something that think that that did
neurons in that in the phobia need to
deal with is this something maybe we
might be sort of extra hardware to to
deal with and so enter your um Barak
where is your yeah who's here so this is
a paper that he wrote a while back a few
about eight years ago so that was
extremely highly influential on to me so
so actually I did my PhD thesis with
Charlie Anderson and David venison they
proposed at that time a
shifter circuit model for how the cortex
might compensate for these drift motions
in the retina and one of the projects I
was supposed to do my thesis for my
thesis would sort of implement that and
show how that could work and it just
seemed kind of too challenging to me so
I've moved to this problem of visual
attention and that kind of dominated
most of my time and it meant to come
back to this but then you know your uh
wrote this paper and showed Wow it can
work it actually works okay this is this
algorithm for doing a motion
compensation neural circuitry and so
this is this is the basic idea so the
first argument I think he makes in this
paper which is really really important
is that first of all you cannot ignore
these motions the cortex has to somehow
take this motion into account so this is
just showing a simulation of a of an e
sitting on the retina and so then in the
case where it's stationary over time and
then when it's drifting so if that
pattern is drifting and because the the
information about that pattern is is
getting relate to the cortex by spikes
by spiking neurons the cortex has to
integrate that information over time and
what he showed here is that an ideal
observer just trying to interpret these
spikes some meaning over time if you
just sort of did a naive integration
over time you would basically obliterate
the pattern so an ideal observer would
fail at accounting for perception just
based on everything we know about you
know realistic firing rates and the
magnitude of this drift motion and so
forth so the only way to explain the
fact that you can read the C is that
somehow the cortex in the process of
integrating this information from from
that from the retina has to take into
account the drift motions and in its
computation okay and what he proposed
here is a very specific model for doing
that whereby the cortex disentangle this
information about what and where so a
tray basically tries to take all these
spikes coming in and saying okay we'll
look these spikes coming in are relaying
some invariant pattern there's some kind
of unchanging pattern there
that's simply moving over time so my job
is to infer what that pattern is the
invariant part and separate it from the
motion the invariant the variant apart
okay so the things there the motion is
changing over time yeah
in this case you saw in your arms mildly
I was just Brownian kind of a Brownian
model of the diffusion model of drift
okay so there's a verse then he's sort
of you know it's a Bayesian model
dynamic image stabilization so he sort
of took a full Bayesian approach to this
from very like first principles approach
and developed this very elegant model
showing how you could have a circuit a
neural circuit in the cortex that could
do the simultaneously inference of the
what part the form separate the form
from the motion for purely from the
retinal spikes and importantly that
computation involves an inter a
multiplicative interaction between these
two streams okay so the system is trying
to estimate the position
multiplicatively gates the information
from the retina to these neurons
representing the shape and the neurons
representing the shape multiplicatively
gate this information from the retina to
the neurons estimating estimating the
the position okay so that so I think
that's another sort of key ideas that to
do this to do that this is a person of
fundamental computation that has to
happen and the nature of this
computation is that these two streams
have to interact and this is really sort
of at odds with a traditional view so
most of the models we see out there and
visual neuroscience form and motion are
typically computed in different pathways
we have one pathway for computing
extracting in variances and doing
pooling which kind of ignores the motion
and another pathway which does motion
energy and ignores the shape and the the
release or the the the approach here is
to say well that's wrong that's not
going to work that's not mathematically
sufficient to solve this problem and the
correct structure of this problem is
that you have to do this kind of
simultaneous estimation of these two
things and the estimation of one the
pains on the estimation of the other
very similar to what's called slam or
simultaneously something is localization
and mapping in robotics it's a very sort
of similar mathematical structure to
this algorithm the estimation of one
depends on the other that you have to
interact as they effort infer they can't
sort of just do it independently you
can't just have independent streams that
do that okay so that's I think one
really important contribution yura made
it very inspired us and in the lab to
start thinking about how you can sort of
take this model a step further and
extend it to grayscale patterns so his
model just dealt with binary patterns
how you could extend it to grayscale
patterns like images and also natural
images not just sort of letters of ease
but sort of things that actually would
be in a natural image
and another interesting thing that was
happening along at the same time as an
Austin Austin weirdest lab together with
Kavita Ratna MS student he was showing
that this this drift motion actually
helps you okay and so it's not like just
some kind of you know maybe hindrance
maybe maybe it's a it's a it actually
helps us this is just showing that
experiment here so this is just showing
the case of a naturally drifting on to
the on the retina due to the eyes own
drift motion the case where they
stabilize because they're tracking the
eye in real-time they can exactly
compensate for that motion in rendering
the pattern and stabilize on the retina
and then a third incongruent condition
where because they're tracking
everything exactly they can not only
stabilize it but they they can introduce
motion of their own choosing okay and
make do it make this sort of a dance
around however they want so that's
consistent or inconsistent with eye
motion so what they show here is first
of all in the natural condition you do
better so this is just a simple case
where you're trying to discriminate
which of four orientations that II is
pointing you do better when in under
natural motion conditions then when it's
stabilized so stabilizing it actually
hurts you and this is not simply because
it's fading because the duration of this
is much less than a second so it only
fades after after about a second or two
okay so this is well before the time
that it starts to fade and and then also
in the incongruent conditioned it's so
any kind of motion basically that has
the same statistical characteristics as
the eye motion helps you okay oh boy
because they're tracking the eye motion
in real time as the retina moves yeah
and so they can they can they can they
can exactly track it okay so that you're
gonna be just maybe get it is just why
might this help you when so thought
about why it might help you is because
there's a there's gaps between these
cones and these cones are not spaced
like completely in a regular lattice
they have different gain factors
different color selectivity some RL some
RM they're kind of clumped in groups
according to lrm and so one thought is
that to make a pattern to sort of sort
of smooth over this in these in
homogeneity in homogeneity in the retina
that one strategy you might use is to
actually drift the pattern
average disappearance over these
different cones as you do so so it's
kind of related to super resolution
techniques that people use in other
fields yeah it's just you just random
motion that was not related to the I not
random but completely unrelated motions
of the eyes on motion yeah so it's just
basically another motion sample that the
subject made it wasn't my date they I
don't think they tried to optimize that
they were job no actually in this case
in that you can see the motion but you
can still read it okay so here here it
looks stable here it appears to move and
and but it helps you see motion in the
other keys so this means that there must
be some parallel sensory signal that
tells the cortex how this eye is
drifting because otherwise what would
you want case okay so then you know this
is something like subjects debate I mean
whether there's a friend's copy of this
drift so there might be a direct signal
maybe there's no direct signal but
either way we have a problem how do we
use that signal okay let's say someone
even gave it to us how do we use it and
let's take take a worst-case scenario
let's say we didn't have it how would we
get that or even if we did get a signal
is probably gonna be a noisy signal
right and we'd sort of want to take a
combination of the images of the retinas
own data and the motion to refer
elements in the visual scene which are
not competing in this apparatus yes
showing that in fact in other situations
experiment set up a little bit
differently as subjects we're not able
to
between their own eyes mo okay all right
yeah yeah the reference frame is very
important here actually yeah no no it
just is what it's fixed in there
yeah there's a very nice paper about by
David era thorne where he sort of looked
at all the motion conditions that create
stable or non stable percept and yeah in
Journal of vision yeah slightly I mean
you know this yeah I don't I don't think
they would make a big deal about the
fact that it's better but it does it's
it you know it was amazing that it's as
good so but yeah it's even a tiny bit
better but why who knows I we are they
have a good explanation for that yeah
okay no no no just that motion helps any
kind of motion yeah it doesn't
necessarily say that the emotion is
there is helps the brain do something it
just might say that the brain is usual
to this kind of motion any usual
used to treat it well we're gonna go
back to your on Barack's argument which
is the from a dual absorber point a
ideal observer point of view you're just
getting these spikes from the retina and
you're trying to figure out what's the
hell what's there you have to integrate
over time okay and if this patter is
moving around while you're integrating
you are toast and so you need something
you know so this it's not just sort of
like do I have motion so I'll recognize
it now I have to use the motion to in a
computer computation to do that first
month of them if one is that you're in
the retina you're up against time it's
because the photoreceptors are so slow
so but the ganglion cells are ready to
go so you just check you just compute a
temporal derivative but you do and doing
the motion so that they get you the
signal and then when you get to the say
the LD inner something one of those
samples waiting for they're waiting for
the temporal copies to come and so if
you wanted to do do your proposal that
that would be my site
there might be other okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna toss out one model here for how it
might happen and it's not the only model
there's a definitely alternative but but
there has to be my main point here if
there's anything you get from this it
has to be something that's non-trivial
just move on let me add tiny okay so
maybe okay and so I aren't ACOG these
are the drift so the fixation alive
movements are composed these two parts
fixation 'l i mean just a drifts and
then correct a saccade drift and then
saccade drift and corrective saccade in
fact in many subjects if you point out
to them they're making these corrective
cicadas they'll stop doing it and it's
all drift because the drift is sort of
the main mode of this is of this
movement we're worrying about okay so
Alex Anderson this is Alex and came out
this nifty model basically very similar
to our model of proper stick models who
do this inference and it works with
grayscale images and I'll just so it's
basically a dynamic routing circuit so
the idea is these neurons that are
estimating position dynamically gate the
connections from retina cortex and that
the basic also as you estimate a pattern
as you build up an estimate the pattern
as the cross correlation of that
estimate with the incoming spikes that
gives you the estimate of the position
this is kind of updated in a common
filter like update so this is basically
alternating m-step for doing this
inference very similar to what you're
I'm kind of laid out except now we can
Abbott work with grayscale patterns this
isn't the grayscale pattern yet but it's
just that the II moving around so the
simulation so this is just so that looks
like an e drifting across the cones this
shows the pattern getting slowly built
up in the cortex well you know within
about 700 milliseconds the spikes from
on cells the spikes from off cells so
basically again this is the thing to
appreciate is that this is the pattern
that your brain has to work with you're
just getting these spikes and from these
spikes coming and you have to say that's
an e okay and and this is the estimation
the pattern coming in so it all works it
helps you improve the estimate so the
motion in the in the model that
corroborates the experiments that is
showing how this drift can actually help
you but also interesting it helps in the
case of cone loss so this is something
as well known as subjects that have cone
degeneration
they can lose up to 50% of their cones
and they still have normal acuity okay
so this is one potential explanation for
how that's possible is this drift
actually helps you recover because it's
moving the pattern over different cones
and integrating over time is going to
help you and then finally we've we've
extended this model to natural images
and in that case with sort of arbitrary
grayscale patterns when you leave a
sparse coding model rather than just
sort of estimating pixels now you're
actually estimating the coefficients of
these Gabor functions so it's more like
a maybe a model sort of v1 model that
you can so it's all knowing love where
you have a much Bank of oriented filters
and these are updating estimates of
their activity over time to sort of pull
out a stable representation of shape in
terms of the scope or basis over time
okay so the so the net points I'm gonna
leave you with is that there are a lot
of funky things about the foveal
representation in in V one and also LG
on a lot of things I hope we have don't
have any understanding of art right now
from a computational point of view but
make it you know really qualitatively
different kind of computation I think
that's something for the community to be
aware of and to think about in building
computational models and and finally
that the one thing that we know these
circuits in phobia must do is they have
to somehow take into account this motion
this due to drift and and one
possibilities they do this through this
kind of routing process multiplicative
eating of spikes coming in all right
that's that's that's it
we can probably take a question or two
so in the model do the neurons is is
there an implicit topology within the
neurons so does one spike no that's my
neighbor
let's see within the within the neuron
it's representing the shape right now no
it's just a list of neurons but in the
neurons representing position there's
basically like a diffusion a motion
prior that says you know if I'm here of
my current estimate is here then my next
estimate is gonna be nearby okay so
there is a topology that we could
shuffle the spike train yeah sure yeah
it's just wiring yeah I'm sure something
else is degraded right it's just that I
think for the the way they measure
acuity in the laboratory is by these
sort of funny tasks like EE and final
orientation is that so yeah exactly I'm
sure if you challenge them in other ways
you would see them into a thought that
you can lose fifty percent later on so
we imagine to the computation is done in
the cortex but you mentioned this
intriguing fact that there's a large
expansion to LGN already in the LGN yes
well so as maria's pointed out I mean
there's those those neurons in the LG
and the elegent are kind of private
they're not sort of spreading
information other than through the
reticular nucleus so you'd have to sort
of figure out a funky computation why
bright you can only use rather diffuse
inhibition to other neurons so I think
you need something like cortical
circuitry to do this it seems to me but
that's there he gives you this expansion
yeah why you need this many it doesn't
explain that right why you need 10 times
as many no of course not but it's just
again this isn't the classic sort of
special things in the fovea that might
you're not gonna find elsewhere that's
the way to think about it yeah
what's this colored images of this
resolution and well sure I mean if you
if you're representing now gray scales
that signal-to-noise issues are much
different
right you have much more information per
pixel so that's the regime we're trying
to go into now is like realistic you
know grayscale patterns or color color
patterns ultimately and I think that's
another place where this is going to
help you tremendously is inferring you
know the full color gamut the color
image from a moving camera and then
maybe something we want to talk to Apple
or somebody about you know it's like
maybe this is a way that motion can help
you in real cameras because in real
cameras you have this bear pattern where
the color sensors are inter digitated
and they play all these kind of games
after the fact to fix it up and to
pretend as though you have an RGB sensor
at each pixel and this might be another
way of doing that to just use the
natural jitter of your hand when you
hold the camera and my people maybe can
help you by doing this experiment with
balloons for example because then that
would target just yeah well I mean I
think the idea is to do the e task here
you're using your parvo system because
the Magno cells are just gonna be too
big for that yes okay yeah okay yeah
right good let's test it right right
right now agree yeah that you could
certainly maybe isolate out that way
right
you said that it takes $700 and I don't
know perhaps literally to take them but
shouldn't be should we be a little bit
concerned about that given that
fixations are typically you know a
couple hundred milliseconds and also you
know we know we can do with RSVP images
coming in 50 milliseconds of pop and and
do very fine discriminations is that
drift I don't think I mean I think the
700 is Alex's interior I think but
that's sort of like a long end of the
spectrum so I don't think you have to
integrate that long before you see the
benefit and again these these sort of
drift periods they can actually be quite
quite quite long before you make you
know a saccade
[Applause]